- Hey guys, How's it going?
Today we're gonna be unboxing
the new Nintendo Switch,
it comes out on March third.
So a huge thank you to
Nintendo for sending me
an early advanced console and
I am so incredibly grateful,
so thank you guys so much.
Let's get into the unboxing, now.
(knife clicks)
I already started cutting into it.
Oh, never ever cut towards yourself,
especially with this
ridiculously sharp knife.
(groans)
I'm so excited!
There's Zelda Amiibo,
I'm so freaking excited!
I've been meaning for the
longest time to do an entire
Amiibo collection because
I have almost all of them.
So one of these days soon, look for that,
but right now let's
just...(breathless exclamation)
This is probably one of
the most incredible Amiibo
that I've ever seen, it's the Guardian.
Zelda, oh she looks so pretty.
Oh boy! Here he is!
Sweet, beautiful Switch.
Look how cute this
little, tiny cartridge is.
It's like the size of my Iphone.
Time to open it up!
Oh my. You're beautiful.
I am so excited, this is the neon version.
We've got our two
Joy-Con controllers here.
It seems way more neon than
the New York event I went to
because the coloring in
that event was so bright,
that you actually didn't get a good chance
to really check out the colors of these.
Oh it feels good. (clicking)
(upbeat music)
(chuckles) There we go, switch 'em around!
Switch 'em around, did you get it?
Did you get the joke?
Look at this, this is the Switch itself.
I'm gonna get this so smudgy
and like point five seconds.
Lift off the top.
More items, we've got our Joy-Con straps!
Let's put these in here.
Let's put the next side in,
so there's a little
tiny groove right here,
and you just slide this
right in just like this.
This looks so cool, I
absolutely love these colors.
I think I'm gonna go get
a manicure this color.
So we got controller, we
got our Switch screen,
we've got a HDMI cable.
You know what that looks like,
and if you don't..
There's the charger.
What's over here?
Oooh!
The Switch, essentially.
Not really sure the technical names
that they're calling everything,
I probably should've looked that up,
but I would call this
the Switch converter.
It essentially converts what is happening
here on your little tablet.
This plugs right into your TV
and from there it switches tablet to TV.
It's the switcher.
Switch it up.
Got your AC adapter here, USB, HDMI out,
and right inside here you can see
there is a little
docking port right there.
Ooh our other Joy-Con strap.
This box is really pretty too.
I kinda wanna save it.
So to release these, you just have to
push this little button
right here, pull up.
And connecting the Joy-Cons
to the tablet, just as easy.
(upbeat music)
It feels pretty solid,
it's a nice substantial feel.
And there we go, switched in.
I like how this kinda
hides all of the cords.
So here it is, this is gonna
look really good in my office,
I could also coordinate my lights
to go with the colors of the controllers.
So here's where the game card is inserted.
Since we're here I guess we might as well,
take a peek at what the
cartridge looks like.
It's so little, it's like
the size of an SD card.
Is it supposed to make that noise?
It's got a real SD card feel to it.
And for a size comparison
of the little case.
Not too much though. (giggles)
It definitely is a little bit bigger.
Well since we're here,
I might as well unbox
these Amiibo as well.
Let's do Zelda first.
(upbeat music)
This is our Link Rider.
Oh these look really good.
The detail's incredible.
This is probably the most
realistic I think of any..
What's that little..?
Is this snow? Is that a little snowbank?
(upbeat music)
Oh great smell, a very
good smell to this guy.
God, the detail, I just can't get over it.
They did such a good job with these.
I'm super impressed.
Well I guess now it's time for
a nice little slowmo video
montage of this sexy Switch.
(calm electronic music)
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you guys enjoy this video.
I'm super excited about the Switch
and all of the games coming
out for it later this year.
I'm gonna be posting a Nintendo
Switch setup in my office.
So I'll be giving you a setup tour
of where I'm gonna be setting it
and a tour of sorta my gaming setup,
which is directly behind
where I'm filming right now.
See, the two cameras, two monitors,
so I can see what I'm doing, office.
All right, well that's it,
I'll see you guys soon, bye!
I've messed things up in boxes before
so there is a possibility
of messing this up.
I mean nothing is ever guaranteed.
That's causing a little bit of a back up.
Oh God!
(slowed) Back up. Oh God!
(laughter)